[Music]  [Music]  go to the bathroom right now build it  raise everybody's so obsessed with boobs  aren't you guys liked it if girls looked  at your dicks all the time the awesome  new penis is comparable to that of a  baby not growing is there something  wrong with me are we just a couple of  freaks  my mom says real beauty is on the inside  loser : nuts packed with crap I just  don't think boys care that we're smart  you live in a society that fixates on  the female form in a psychologically  estimating way I can't be horny and  still be a decent guy  my girl's parents are going through a  d-box and she needs to act that was  beautiful  no I'm just trying to be normal  [Music]  oh my god feldheim Gina  we are gossiping Oh what did you just  say you're a this is vodka listen you  want me sharper what  blow me into the toilet I want someone  to come in here and be like you use pew  [Music]  [Music]